well seeing how last year everyone
seemed to enjoy seeing me get tortured
with the Disney sequels this year I'm
gonna do something kind of similar at
least I think it's similar in that I
haven't seen any of the subject matter
I'm gonna review this month I'm talking
about the Disney Channel original movies
now seeing how they started in 1997 I'm
not gonna lie they were a little past my
time so I didn't grow up with any of
these why are they worth talking about
them well because the Disney Channel
Original Movies got so popular that
almost helped define a whole generation
okay not too fine but it was a big part
of it it was too many kids would say
Ninja Turtles was to me or he-man or
transformers or any of these other silly
things that a lot of people my
generation grew up with yeah they were
ridiculous but they also left an impact
for some reason well all through the
month of December I'm gonna take a look
at these films and tried to figure out
why they were so popular if they deserve
to be so popular and if they hold up as
an adult or were they only meant for
kids and even if so were they really any
good for kids now if you take a look you
quickly realize there are a ton of these
movies that go way beyond how many days
there are in December so I'm only gonna
try and do the most popular ones and if
there were ever any sequels to did they
deserve the attention the popularity
well there's only one way to find out I
have no idea if I'm in for something
great or something terrible or both I'm
curious to see what a generation under
me grew up with and if it actually holds
up at all some of these are even movies
based on shows I'll get an idea what
kind of shows kids we're watching - am I
in for a wild adventure or nothing but
pain there's only one way to find out
this is Disney summer the Disney Channel
original movies
[Music]
you